desfile militar en sant lluís una de las
primeras ciudades francesas liberadas de
la ocupación nazi en la segunda guerra
mundial el evento forma parte de las
conmemoraciones anuales del llamado día
de mientras los habitantes de la ciudad
se alineaban para mostrar su gratitud
los veteranos del día de que regresan
dicen que la experiencia es agridulce
[Aplausos]
recuerdo a algunos buenos amigos que se
perdieron allí
es un poco emotivo
hace 78 años el 6 de junio unas 160.000
tropas aliadas desembarcaron en la costa
de normandía en las playas denominadas
omaha yuta y 1 short y world
los veteranos sus familias y los
visitantes desafiaron el tiempo lluvioso
para presentar sus honores a los que
lucharon y murieron durante la operación
overlord
lo primero que recordamos son los pobres
muchachos que no volvieron tuvimos
suerte
pero pensamos en todos esos pobres
muchachos que no salieron de la playa
ese día ese día fue su último día pero
siempre están en nuestra mente
para algunos las conmemoraciones de este
año tienen un significado especial ya
que europa está de nuevo en guerra tras
la invasión rusa de ucrania mary scott
que sirvió como radio transmisor a
codificada reflexionó sobre los combates
en ese país
porque no podemos aprender de las
experiencias pasadas porque no podemos
hacer lo que nos pasa es una locura así
que si la guerra debería enseñarnos algo
pero nunca parece perdurar durante mucho
tiempo teilón
tras dos años de restricciones por la
pandemia que redujeron el número de
visitantes se espera que miles de
personas asistan a los eventos de este
año